歡迎收看趙華
我是趙華
我是艾倫
今天不放紙箱了
今天不用放
來我送你一個東西
紙上富貴
今天就是紙上富貴
你很有心耶
沒有賣的話就是紙上富貴
最近都有道具耶
是不是
不錯不錯
我們今天台灣股市又跌了一個2000點
而且今天4萬點的大關
是一度失守的
而且那個失守不是失守一兩百點
我看它直接回收到
三萬九千三百多
對
對啊
那個就是這樣一啾
這樣下去
是 摸到半年線
對 但是好家在
今天有拉了一個
700點的下影線
是 對 盡力的
那今天在跌什麼呢
今天當然美股來說
就是有康寧的財報
是
怎樣了
康寧財報其實沒有不好
對啊
那韓股呢
有海力士的財報
海力社财报也没有不好
其实我今天有看
它海力是最多跌到接近19%
但尾盘只跌9%
有拉上来
对 它们也是一个极限拉台
那今天也是一样
我们就是整个亚洲股市一起向下摔
然后一起拉一些尾盘这样
好 当然雄本的话也发生了
7.1的大地震
昨天下午录影的时候发生的
有一些伤亡
真的是令人家觉得是蛮感叹的
希望平安
对 天由日本
不過因為台積電在熊本油場
所以昨天晚上台積電的ADI
也是率先往下殺
這些綜合性的因素
在美日台韓都造成了影響
那這樣有叫做加速乾地嗎
其實我覺得有一點
我覺得明天應該有機會
反個談一下
好 所以我們趕快來解讀一下
昨天有講到烏漏偏峰
連夜雨
這個雨還在下
沒錯 而且有越下越大的感覺
我們先來快速的瀏覽一下
这个海力士跟康宁的财报
其实我觉得讲的都还OK
对 当然啦
它营收有点没有符合市场预期
然后利润也是有点没符合预期
那有几个原因
就是他们有说传统记忆底涨价
HBM因为比重比较高
没有完全吃到
这个也很莫名其妙
以前是这个DDR4比较落后
所以未来要涨价涨HBM
然后DDR4原本一开始很强
因为是这个利多去拉台
那后面说因为HBM
可能比重要越高
所以DDR的股票开始跌
那现在又说
因为它没有吃到DDR4
所以它股价也要跌
到底要怎样
没错
对 所以我觉得就是目前
现在就是见空说空
另外一个是康宁
康宁重点优于预期
但财测仅接近预期
又来了
不行
对 99分不行
你要101分
营收都是优于预期的
目前来说整个的光通讯
深层CI的产品
已經倍增了有亞馬遜跟輝達的
大型客戶的單
再來目前的猜測是
0.85到0.89 EPS
營收是49到50億
那麼預期其實就在這個區間內
所以它沒有亮點
不是啊
而且它光通訊的收益
其實是超乎市場預期的
沒錯 它是年正32%
兼CPU殺一排綠燈
開一盤就變
對 就因為這個消息
對啊 就很辛苦
我覺得就是一個
現在就是行情整體
市場就是在修正的氛圍
要來還的
沒錯 那我們來看到的
台積電雄本廠
這個日本有個7.1級的大地震
它跑的比較偏的是成熟製程
有索尼半導體的CMOS
然後還有這個車用晶片
這些產品都已經獲得認證綁定了
短期間內比較難
去有其他廠區去做接受
所以目前看起來
可是我看台積電還有說
是廠區跟人員是沒有太大的傷亡的
對 那真的是不幸中的大幸
那後面要觀察的就是整個供應鏈
因為它這個是一個
整個的產業圖嘛
然後他們的熊本聚落
都會跟
就會反正
大家都是互相有些關係的啊
你是供應鏈啊
你是上下游的關係
所以呢
其實不只是看台積電
台積電如果它的廠沒問題
那旁邊的供應的東西
能不能會不會也沒問題
反而就是後面
我們要去觀察了一個重點
那再來台灣相關族群呢
當然就是一些我們的供應鏈啊
或者是說
日本出貨比重比較高的
半導體設備廠
還有成熟製程使用的
化學材料的供應商
這個是我們台灣
可能要稍微注意的
那這個新聞出來
確實在台積電ADR
也稍微反映了一下
那這個就看後續
目前看起來他們說出來的數字是
不是數字 數字
說出來的講法是還好
影響程度不大
要是以前啊
可能又會開始聯想
哇 熊本有地震
那就也許不會在熊本擴散
去其他的地方
不會有二場了
或者是成熟志成這邊的話
他不過
那可能就會連電受惠
可是今天都沒有
今天都一樣還是無差別的下殺
今天開盤就是大家就
什麼都是在殺
沒錯
台積電自己還殺得少
設備股也還是在殺
沒錯 全部都很辛苦
所以這是近這一兩天的一些新聞
好 再來我們還是要回歸
看到了整個技術面的狀態
台灣股市我們就一樣
兩大重點
底部爆大量跟突破下降趨勢線
就會是指紋的效應
那今天台灣股市
我們昨天有說
這平台也破了
可能就要往4萬去做靠攏了
那今天先不要說靠攏
直接盤中有做跌破
好家債 收盤是站上的
好 收盘是有收缴的
其实那一天是礼拜五的
史上最大跌点
两天就又把这个
史上最大跌点也cover过去了
没错 两天就4000点去了
那这个4000点呢
我今天有看到
大概1点快50分左右
看到新闻
说我们这个航库进场护盘
真的有人在呼喊国安基金了
看来有点严重了
确实 因为我们不要看说
他护什么盘
这个还没进入熊市
这不今天高点
进入熊市了吧
不是跌快兩成了
沒有跌18%而已
今天跌18%而已
還差2%
對 18.8% 差1.2%
貴買是29%
所以以貴買來講
確實是雄市
對 那大家就會去想
你才漲 跌這樣
那為什麼大家要拚命去喊
因為只有台積電
是跟它漲得差不多
其他你去看什麼台達電
聯發科
然後還有什麼
這個鴻海廣達還好
什麼聯電
其他的
那個下去都是
三成 四成以上
所以雖然我們指數看起來還好
但是整个个股的跌幅
其实是非常严重的
真的是
我只能说严重
有的是已经打到三
就是打三折
对的
跌到七成的都有
没有错
那这个就会是
可能需要讨论的
但是毕竟股市还是在四万点
对
所以你说单靠指数
单看指数
我觉得好像也不至于到护盘
但看个股好像真的
有讨论空间
但是又不太可能只护个股
没错
所以不管
我们就回来看
这台湾股市
今天总算这个不至于到爆量
今天的量有到1.1兆
那不至于到爆量
大概就是一个底部出量
那底部出量是好事嘛
因为我们现阶段说
如果你是空方结构
在一个相对低点
能够爆一个量出来
那就是一方面卖的人很多
一方面承接的人也很多
那今天的量
其实后面有一点放不太大的原因
是因为很多全资股都跌停板
是
对所以没有人要买嘛
对啊你卖不下去了
那就成交量自然会萎缩起来
所以我们来看一下
今天这个低点
就会是一个短线非常重要的支撑
看能不能在这边主抵
看能不能如果真的要下去
能不能赶快极限拉抬
拉一个长的爆量的一个下影线
那我觉得都可以是
短线视为要准备主抵的讯号
那另外贵买指数也是一样
我们直接回测到了
是4月的期长点
回到4月的期长点
然后大概是半个
三个礼拜的时间
跌了大概三个月的长点
然后就直接回测到了低点了
那今天呢小幅出量
2000亿的量
所以整个桂码还是很辛苦
那目前来说我们就看一下
年限的位置跟这个
起涨点的支撑区
能不能在这边先不破底
然后也是一样
向上要去消化我们绿色化出来的
下降趋势线
所以目前来说
短线我觉得有机会跌升反弹
但是跌升反弹能不能形成转折
那个可能是后面
再过几天要观察的
这个是目前的
急速面的状态
那在我们快速的去浏览
今天有比较主指标的三家公司
好 說會 星星
EPF的星星其實數字都很漂亮
營收年增32%
EPS42000%
好像去年Q2好像賺0點多塊而已
然後再來毛利率還OK
就是24.8%
那EPS整年上半年是年增1787%
不能再高了 非常高
好 那再來我們看一下
整個的GPU也好
ASEC也好 HPC也好
全部的產值都是上修的
那AIA產品接下來會占比
下半年可提升到70%
那另外ABF呢
目前来说也是采用一个
价格滚动式的调整向上
那再来毛利率呢
有机会优于第二季
第二季目前是接近25%
所以第三季有机会再高一点
再来这本支出非常高
537亿
另外呢法说呢
整个光模组会在Q4的时候
开出残忍
那玻璃机板呢
有说大规模量产的几率不高
所以目前来说
其实我觉得以数字跟猜测来讲
还可以啦
因為它的財物數字是昨天就出來了
所以昨天我們就說
這數字很漂亮
今天是先開紅
後面咕嚕咕嚕又跌停板
沒錯 沒多久就跌停板
所以我覺得這個都是
基本面跟技術面上的脫鉤
脫鉤了 沒錯
其實不只是它
很多個股都脫鉤
那你也不能
好像也不能講脫鉤
因為畢竟它前面也是長得很兇
可是現在回測的幅度
其實真的有一點點
我覺得都已經有跌出價值來了
對 所以我們後面持續關注
今天也是底部跌停有出一个量了
看能不能有一个比较明确的
止跌讯号出现
再来讨论了
这个是新兴的部分
上涨的时候常常说
这个EPS不重要了
因为已经飞天了
现在很重要了
现在我们看到国具
国具稍微比较温一点点
营收是35%年增
EPS 88%年增
那再来毛利率到38.5%了
Q1有到38.1%
微幅上涨
然后EPS则是年增65%
整体来讲的话
预期来讲
第三季应该还是会叫第二季
去做温和的成长
温和不够
对 只能不能不能
要有强劲两个字
要发个脾气
没错
但是目前看起来确实就是温和
然后AI应用需求是持续扩大的
第三季的产能利用率会拉到90%以上
毛利率跟盈利率都会是一个成长的趋势
那不过他也有说
就是因为原材料成本上升
跟品质的标准品的需求增加
所以有抵消部分获利
这个也是他可能要涨价的一个原因
那国具我们就是涨这样
这就是一个圣诞树
这样圣诞树
我们现在才7月
我们就要12月圣诞树了吗
现在体感就像12月
还是像富士山上面已经积雪了
没错
我在雪山有救过国具吗
很辛苦
但是这一档个股
我们等一下给来宾
特别解说一下
没错
有来宾今天决定介入他了
没错没错
我們給有買的人來講
好 再來最後一個就是聯電
怎麼樣呢
聯電都是搞到最晚
它五點才開
對 那聯電營收年增17%
EPS年增377%
毛利率較Q1也成長了大概3%多
就是原本29.2到32.5%
上半年賺了4.68元
是喔 然後再來年增251.9%
今年上半年就賺了接近5塊
下半年如果再給它賺個5塊
那大概就是賺9塊到10塊
那我們現在股價是102塊
所以這個本益比極低
所以我覺得它這個
目前本益比大概11倍左右而已
是 它又回到10倍附近
沒錯 用明年的本益比算
真的是已經個位數的本益比
當然沒話說
因為最近有ETF在賣股
然後可能前面比較強勢又融資比較多 融資多沒錯 所以目前來說整體來講其實我覺得這整體的數字開出來應該都還算不錯然後展望也是很多利多
西光子等等的跟英特爾合作
所以我覺得它的未來展望
應該還是都是好的
但這一波一樣
跟新星跟國劇一樣
就是無差別攻擊
其實也不只是他們三個
只是今天剛好開法說
所以來跟大家講一下
那聯電也是一樣
今天的下跌
已經有出一個相對比較大的量了
那也是要等一個
今天的低點不要再破底
然後向上攻擊的時候
能夠把一些空方趨勢化解掉
我覺得未來才有比較好的機會
對 那目前也是融資越來越低了
然後投信 其實投信還在買
但是被動式的一些ETF
是把它賣掉的
所以目前的壓力
是稍微更重一點點
我們就後續持續關心它
好 這個是今天的法說
搞不好被動式後面會賣回來
因為之前有的賣掉
是因為它已經沒有高值利率了
對啊 他跌到這邊
它的殖利率又回來了
不管有沒有出息
就它的那個殖利率吸引力
對比之下是會回來的
是的
那今天呢
其實最近這一陣子
比較強勢抗鐵的族群
其實就是一個ODM廠
你可以把它區別在AI伺服器
或者說板卡
或者說AIPC
對 那這個相關的裡面
有一個AMD的新機櫃
在上個禮拜有去做一個發酵
對 然後呢
這一個黃仁軒有去偽創站台
所以這些相關的概念股
其實是最近比較抗疊的
也就是說我幫大家整理好了
Helios概念股跟台長老AI
明天呢
Jala8早上8點半
會幫大家準時發送
Helios
因為我就跟艾倫討論很久
大家先掃QRQ
我說為什麼不是Helios
或是Halios
或是Holios
因為螞蟻有四種叫聲
如果知道的觀眾朋友
可以留言給我們
我真的不知道
等一下再跟大家講
為什麼會有這個聯想
先掃一下
明天早上8點半
這個Helios概念股
以及老AI
有機會也是成為
第一是資金避風港
第二還是要需要他們當領頭羊
重啟一波AI的掌勢
所以下一段節目我們要來分享
有哪一些老AI會具備
這樣子的條件
好 來吧
這個半導體股災
其實AMD從高點摔下來
也摔了兩成
但是如果大家有去看AMD的
股價的走勢
其實它是在高檔震盪的
對 其實是相對抗震的
我是說對比之下
畢竟也是摔兩成
那之前AMD大會
有上修AI的潛在市場規模
像是加速器會到1.4兆
未來兩顆GPU會搭配
兩顆CPU就1比2
對 一顆GPU跟兩顆CPU
所以CPU的伺服器的這一個
將會產值
整個市值會突破2000億美元
那他剛提到這個Helios
在9月會是出貨
這個是對比的就是
回答的Varubin的這個機櫃
然後OpenAI已經有說
要開始部署了
所以目前這一些AMD的目標價
都被整個外資
是做一個調升的
沒錯
所以這個是一些相關的
報告的數據給大家參考一下
也就是說其實我們
雖然現在半導體是重災區
但是在AI發展之下
半导体它确实目前看起来
都还是在蓬勃发展的
那我觉得就是基本面
跟技术面上的矛盾大对决
真的因为之前在网上飞的时候
我们画面都只能看技术面了
但现在也会满地都可以发现
本益比合理的公司越来越多
是的
这个就是一个
有时候股市就是长这样子
那我们来看一下
这个相关的ODM厂
其实这一次AMD
有所谓的Venus跟Helios
那裡面呢
市場有指名13家的相關供應鏈
這一波相對抗跌呢
就是偽创跟偽影
帶動了一眾的這一個ODM廠
伺服器代工廠呢
是相對表現比較好的
當然不能說他們沒有跌
確實還是有稍微震盪一下
都到年限了有的
是的 可是呢
因為一方面
他們可能前面就先跌過
先跌了
或者是說前面本來也沒漲
對 也沒漲
用沒漲也沒漲
所以在這一波
這個行情比較不好的過程中
他们反而有一个
大家会注意到他们
因为其他人是跌烂
他是没动
他们那时候有顺势
在六月华人勋来台
参加电脑战的时候
有一波顺势的
人一飞走
全部全部都躺回去
没错 怎么广达
那一大根让上去
但全部回来以后
在这次股灾相较之下
受伤就比较轻微
是的
当然可能普遍
我觉得还是受伤
今天伪创原本也是开高
后面也是走低
音业达也是涨5%
后面变涨2%多
那原本早上这些气势都很强
可是整理大阪不好的时候
多少被拖累
好 那我们来看一下里面几档
我觉得都还是
当然目前这一波领头的伪创
就还是要看一下
伪创呢 目前来说
在前面这个站台的时候
拉了一大根
然后呢 再拉一大根
后面到目前为止
就在过去一个区间震荡
那目前可以看到
整个量价的关系其实呢
是少数偏健康的
因为它现在是多头结构
因为它在全部均线之上
那目前來說它今天回測了前面的缺口位置
回測完之後就拉了一個下影線
可惜它上面也來個上影線
所以目前來說它這邊是一個小小的區間震盪
那我們去關注的就是這個區間震盪
這個高點能不能做突破
或者說這邊能不能先站為全部均線
我覺得可以視為有沒有機會打出一個N字型的
一個行情的機會
那如果行情真的一起走反彈
其實我覺得這種已經相對抗跌的股票
而且量價有關係
所以市場量價有放大
所以市場有在關注的
當行情一轉好的時候
我覺得這種都有機會先動
因為畢竟型態已經好了
市場也有關注
只差一個氣氛要變好
所以氣氛變好他們就有機會
這是偽創
這個大家可以稍微注意一下
另外就偽硬
偽硬的型態差不多
好 再來另外一個就是鴻海
好 鴻海今天跌0.42%
沒錯 算是厲害囉
他盤狀都漲3%
對 但是後來真的是
跌太多了就被拉下來了
是的 那今天也是一樣
我們已經這裡已經有一點
这是一个蛮强劲的支撑区
真的真的
230230这边
你看宏海这一阵子
也就是人来风那一次
所以整个都拉上去
但你可以发现
这边7月在这里
7月台湾股市还没跌
所以它自己先跌了
然后我们这个台湾股市
这一段时间在崩盘
它反而还有占回季先过
所以是一个蛮明确的
在行情不好的时候
有一个资金避风港的效应
那今天做一个回撤
已经拉脚了
所以我觉得这边
有一些赚北比的效应可以出来
就是反正230我跌破就走
那237块
我就最多虧7块
对那虧7块
以现在来算的话
大概虧个2-3%
那这边如果能够拉上去
高点能够做突破
这里也会是一个
不错的形态上的转折
所以我觉得这边
也可以稍微关注一下
鸿海目前来说已经
就已经不是在讲基本面了
反而是少数不用讲基本面
就是技术面是真的
比较扛一点的
对
那当然基本面也是好公司
那如果后面
因为据传
尽管会在开会了嘛
对
今天有點驚動到
我們的政府機構了
是 沒錯
韓韓國安基金
然後金管會也可能要研議一些
股民可以安定信心的方式
是的 那如果要安定指數
那當然鴻海 全止股
我覺得一定不會在名單之外
再來我們來看到的就是華碩
華碩今天也是強的
今天出大量
今天也強
對 你看我們剛剛也是一樣
他也是這一波我拉了快一倍
然後後面疊下來之後
這一波行情這個是7月中
行情在這樣子走
它反而在這樣子走
那當然漲幅沒有很多
只是它也是少數
就是在季線之上
真的現在是季線之上
是少數的股票
不跌就是漲
沒錯 現在真的是這樣
那這裡也拉得出一個
比較緩一點的
一個上升的趨勢的軌道
所以目前來說
它也是一個多方的結構
那當然壓力區在這裡
所以它其實漲到這裡
就稍微有點休息了
不過今天回測到10月均線
又有一個出量
站回全部均線
所以我們也可以觀察的是
這個高點能不能去做突破
做突破這邊也做突破
接下來可以挑戰的是缺口
還有前高的位置
所以目前來說
這個多方結構
也給大家做一些參考
它在最低點有一個大量
好猛喔
對啊 所以其實大盤
也要等這個訊號
沒錯 你看這裡常常下影線
然後碰季線
然後爆大量
所以行情就開始緩電高
當大盤出現類似這樣的訊號的時候
其實大家就可以期待一下
有沒有機會走一些反彈的行情
以上是这三档帮大家介绍一下
好那当然现在的风
虽然风浪大纲也提到了
跌下来价值出现的
本益比合理的
可以重新用基本面评估的股票
反而是变多了
对不对
所以如果有兴趣的朋友
也欢迎加入一下
赵华艾伦说的YouTube频道
今天节目所有的资料图卡
我们都会放在首页的贴文栏
免费提供给大家
那等一下我们有个大来宾
刚刚有提到国具要让他聊
因为他今天等一下会告诉您
他有买的一些股票
而且还有强反弹的一些要诀
真金白银的打进去
我们要听听看
他的理由到底是什么
欢迎回来赵华
今天我想很多人的信息
应该是不足的
但是如果今天愿意告诉大家
已經下去買了的人是不是生人
沒有錯 這位來賓之前跟我說
他邊吃小籠包邊賠錢
他也跟你說嗎
他剛跟我說的
他說小籠包很貴
生煎包
而且他在上海吃完回台灣繼續吃
所以你說今天這位來賓要給大家信心了
而且吃完生煎包之後
他昨天也有跟我說
趙華幸好你沒有跟我一起買
很坦白這樣
不過都是因為策略已經想好
我覺得策略想好是一件
很重要的事情
我們先來歡迎他出場
也是我們非常熟悉的朋友
冠軍操盤手 云翔哥
大家好
好 已經很簡短了
因為大家都 我們很熟了
很熟了
那今天的話
台股一度破了四萬點
然後我就想到
禮拜一我們有碰面
不過云翔哥
你應該買POOT
對
我記得這件事情
記得很清楚
那因為你買POOT
不只是為了你個人
也為了全台股的著想
你買了就會彈
結果呢
結果因為
就是因為
你到底要買禮拜五的
還是買禮拜三的
然後呢
對 想著想著就睡著
什麼啦
所以這兩天下跌要怪雲翔哥
怪 非怪不可
因為雲翔哥買PUT
是台股會長一個很重要的指標
OK
買不到就慘了
好 所以確實是真的滿慘的
好
那現在雲翔哥的持股狀態是如何
有做什麼調整嗎
你看現在說第一個高點
第二個高點 對到第三個
三尊頭
對 類似三尊頭 對
你可以說三重頂 對
那這裡來講就是說
在這樣的一個頸線位置
大概落點剛好在四萬二
也就是說四萬二其實很快
就昨天就已經達到
這個四萬位位置
今天直接跌破 對
那跌破呢
等於是這裡大概會有一個關卡
就是我們講說整數關卡
所以今天確實就是
跌破以後有收為整數關卡
所以我倒覺得4萬是
目前看起來就是第一個
大家可以去看的一個位階
如果真的我們要講說
剛剛趙華講說山峰頭也好
你這個位階要去看它的
往下的滿足點
就是跌破頸線之後
如果這種做法是說
從頸線往上的高點
你把它回推下來對等
所以如果這樣對等的
是要6000點
所以很多人估到所謂的36000
應該是用這樣的估法對 大概景限的高點是6000嘛對不對那你往這個4萬2往下6000呢那剛好就點是6000對不對你4萬2往下6000剛好就是36000
會到36000的意思嗎
其實今天如果那種恐慌性
蔓延
蔓延到隔天以後
基本上大概就很快就到了
尾盤感覺是有一股買的力量
不知道來自哪裡
因為韓國拉了6%
韓國盤中拉
所以最後長下眼線
确实把它拉回这4万
那现在盘后当然指数也是涨了
所以就说希望
我当然自己希望说
这个4万款卡能够守住
因为这两天我是有买的
这两天你就进去了
对 这两天就进去了
虽然说大概部位有点多
可是里面有反一
所以反一如果2000万来讲
就对推
就是你反一是反向的
所以你要对推
比如说2000万
你还对推2000万
所以大概有4000万
等於是push掉
所以如果1億的話
就升6千萬這樣子
今天反映的漲幅
一度好像4%多
我們也非常少
對 5%多
我們也很少看到反映長成那樣子
對
可是我們有跟雲翔哥聊到對不對
這一次反映的效果其實沒有很好
反映效果好像一直都不算太好
這一次更不好
對 更不好
因為台積電撐指數
各股都跌3 40%
因為反映基本上是希望
剛剛艾文講對
就是反映希望是整個全肢股
要下來 重點就在台積電
台積電基本上它的跌幅還是有限
所以整個來講就是說
對等去對沖的這個股票
很多基本上都打到大概七八%以下
所以反過來來講
是說保護的效率不好
唯有一個保護的效率最好就是選擇權
對 沒買
我剛才真的忍不住說
林翔哥你到底要多少借口
忘記了 不好買 睡著了
所以反應大概賺了
大概一兩百萬
可是對於衝票
基本上我講說
大概生煎包一顆50萬對不對
在上海已經吃了20顆
回台灣
回台灣又吃了大概15顆
該去餐了
對 所以就是說目前來講
就是說整體我認為說
只是為4萬我是看第一道關卡
現在來講就是說
如果融資繼續降下來
當然是好的
是好的
就是說總體來講
還是需要把整個台灣的信用
這個部分要能夠稍微消化掉一點
很多人可能今天的感受是
獲利都已經全數回圖
蠻多人是這樣的感受
但是至少不是叫做賠到沒有錢
就是這邊林翔哥
有秀了一個存折
我還很少看到秀對賬
但就算了還秀存折
我教育是要頒
因為今天交易是那個
就翻到一本存折
對 就翻到一本
這個所謂的
我們講說證券戶
對 證券戶存折
那剛好是我第一本
哎唷
你還留著啊
第一次入市
民國78年
你看還在上面
78年你還留著
然後第一筆
第一筒就48萬
這還存在這裡
當時那個薪水
大概一個月大概一萬來塊
所以那時候大概第一筆
那基本上這筆錢
大概到十年
就是說這1989年
到1999年的時候
資產是大概已經做到
大概1500萬
自己當然那時候大概只有
這裡等於是大概22歲
對不對
到這個時間點來講
大概十年30出頭
就還滿得意的對不對
對 會很得意
得意喔
得意的
就這樣做
少年古神
第一批楊雲祥
然後那時候基本上
做法也很簡單
就是因為又考過營運營製造
之前運營就很少了
那考的時候
基本上有考財務報表什麼東西
當然你就會看財務
那也會去推它的本益比嘛
對不對
所以用很簡單的本益比
評估法就好了
對不對
如果我那時候如果這個市場
因為市場平均本益比以前很高
以前的台股的平均本益比
高到1999年曾經來到47倍
平均本益比
那我如果去找一個
這個股票它的本益比很低的
比如說落在20倍左右的本益比
就非常低
因為以前的電子股
大概本益比都平均在三十幾倍
那二十倍來講
如果我能夠到
它本益比變成二十五倍
那也就是代表說我賺了二十五倍
對 這樣懂我意思
所以每這樣子做法
就是去找一個
本益比比較偏低的好股票
那基本上放個正值
基本上它可能會達到
所以是順風球一直做一直做
對
十年耶
十年的順風球
不過就大概兩千年
對 兩千年怎麼了
六個月就破產
為什麼你都不留一點錢
在手上為什麼搞到破產
其實以前就一樣
就是說當你覺得自己很會賺的時候
你基本上就一直擴充你的信用
對 那一年就這樣
在2000年你可以看到
2000年的一個高點落點
在4月 對 大概在10393
那當年是跌到剩下4500戶數
也就是說基本上大概
對 網路泡沫化
3955 到
就那一年
那一年基本上說
當然不會知道
網路泡沫這麼嚴重
所以入場的時候
我還是找到一個很好的股票
本益比基本上不高
因為那時候在除完以後
大概是在260幾塊
也就是說它除完
因為它以前都是
至少是除5塊錢以上
而且有配股票
曾經以前也配過一股配一股
好股票基本上
我認為說這個落點
如果它的本益比
你落點落到20
對
那我認為說
這個基本上放沒有問題
所以進去以後
直到它一個多月以後
就跌破大概是剩下220左右
那我有的方法當然就是攤平
所以我這裡攤了一次
然後又下來
又剩下大概是跌破200
大概170百吧
再攤一次
可是這一次的攤法
我是這樣就是說重壓嘛
所以第二次的攤
已經把錢全部都已經放進去
而且是用融資買到滿
所以第三次的這個錢
是外面借來的錢
你可能會用二胎或什麼樣
反正你能借
像能借 信用能借的
就是借嘛
那到第三次
就是你在借路的時候
這時候你就會開始緊張
為什麼 因為你基本上
沒辦法出場
你出場以後
你這個錢絕對
沒辦法去還這個錢
你解我意思嗎
因為已經幾乎快
都借來的 對 都借來的
所以到後面以後
就是又跌
跌到快160 170的時候
這時候叫做補維持率
也就是說
維持率不能低於120
對不對 那時候
所以你可能把它補到130
然後又跌的時候
你要再借錢
去把這個維持率
多補個幾%
你基本上可以撐住
直到跌破150的時候
直接就是被斷頭
被斷頭 服不了了
你要嘛就是繼續在借錢
你怎麼借
所以斷頭之後
你等於是前面這個錢
全部沒以後
你基本上還會負債
因為你外面的錢還要還
所以負債總共負債300多萬
就等於是1500萬不見以後
還負債300萬 對
所以最後華碩是當年的價格
在94塊5
那坦白講說
這股票好不好 非常好
就是說如果你是用
現金的一個做法
丟的反正沒差
這是一個好股票可以等
華碩後來的94塊5
後來到什麼高點大家都知道
也就是說事實上放到後面
你基本上還是怎麼樣
就還是獲利的
還是賺很多的
可是基本上不是用現金的
用信用交易來講
大家都會出這種問題 對
所以這個也就是說
從這一次發生這個事情以後
我後面就會比較
在自己的信用交易方面
就會保持一定的清醒
原來雲翔哥在2000年
就當過韓國人了
沒有 就當過
就有世代同學
對 他就南韓人耶
因為你總覺得自己很厲害嘛
對 然後大概在
確實在 2006年 2007年那兩年
我就把這個
1500全部賺回來
就是那兩年賺2000萬
可是好辛苦喔
1999年就已經賺到1500了
又花了一段時間又把它賺回來
這時候是負債的
所以後面來講
你等於是四年
有四年當然是
你回歸還是要去
想辦法賺錢對不對
上班賺錢
到後來在2006、2007年
用了一些所謂的
我們講說短線交易
因為台股來講
在這種所謂的
當中交易來講
基本上還是蠻不錯的
因為它是T加2
所以這個我們今天就不講
那我覺得說
以這個來講就是說
總體在這次的交易裡面
我就確實就是說
有人說我很衝
其實我還滿保守的
對 因為在交易裡面
如果現金夠多
基本上你會發現
這樣的交易裡面
我庫存雖然虧了錢
可是我基本上都是現金
當然就是對這塊來講
那當然就會有比較大幫助
那我講說其實這些股票來講
你會發現
這是我自己的一些庫存
我今天就來順便講一下
就秀出來了
國具台青科被動元件
神達 應驗達
這個就是組裝可稱
對 我覺得說被動元件
你說不要去碰
我覺得不能夠這樣來看
為什麼 因為當時你說
1220塊 它的本益比是57倍
對 這時候來講
對我來講我確實不會去碰
甚至在1000塊
我有一些老股市的把它賣掉
對不對 那時候講
後來你看到現在來講
到今天的價格507來講
它的本益比已經回歸到20幾倍
對 也就是說很合理的本益比
可是以今天的這個
當然今天的法說出來以後
當然它的前兩季的獲利
已經不到8塊多
所以今年的數字
應該是比較肯定
因為第三屆也講說會成長
然後毛利也到38.5
就一定很高
所以它明年的估法
是因為會漲價
然後它的營收
還會持續在成長的情況
明年這個法
估算7塊多來講
它的本益比明年只有13倍
也就是說這個底氣是夠的
如果你現在當然
你用現金是分批去買進去
那當然你根本就不會有
這種擔心的問題
所以今天 我是今天進場
好 因為禮拜一
翔哥有來上達人秀
就有講到關注國劇
好兇喔
因為後面又再兩根
所以大家覺得
我也覺得跌得便宜了
可是什麼時候會決定進場
例如今天還是點停盤
為什麼是今天
今天基本上
本來沒有點停盤
如果說實當然
我可能會再反應一下
今天也是慢慢慢慢就殺下去
那今天再一點就是說
第一個
它的一個位接的本益比
我認為是夠低的
去對比明年來講
13倍已經夠低了
我認為說這時候
我可以放一批資金
先放一點進去
所以這個時候來講
是我比較偏向一個基本面
也不是用技術面
因為技術面它是沒有撐的
所以這樣來講就是說
如果能夠有一些資金
去放到說
它的一個基本面
可能會有一個
比較強烈的一個反彈效果
那可能就是說
它可能回到六七百的情況下
那當然你的獲利就會不錯
還有一個點要注意看
看什麼就是說
你的起漲點來自哪裡
就是說這一波的起漲點
比如說國際的起漲點大概330
可是台信科的起漲點大概200
大概202
也就是說目前來講
它已經跌破所謂的起漲區
那這時候來講就是說
這樣的股票來講
相對它的
它的就是等於是
回落的一個位階來講
它的支撐力道會比較強
所以你會發現說
今天它一直都沒有跌停過
同時它等於是尾盤收起來
它等於是有跌大概4 5%
所以相對就會比較強勢
所以這個也是
我會去看這樣的股票的一個因素
另外來講就是
最近比較強的股票
支撐比較強的
我有去看
比如說像神達跟英業達
英業達是老AI這些事情
所以確實他們股票來講
英業達今天還漲
對不對 所以這兩支基本上
還是比較抗跌 有介入
它的一個本益比來講
也是非常非常低的
大概只有10倍
英業達應該比較高一點大概是7倍另外可乘就是我比較長期的一個持有因為我看了等於是它下半年的一個狀況所以目前來講可塵也是很抗疊
可塵也是小哥很喜歡的
長期持有果 兩位已經
對 不過我必須講
就是說在自己的庫存裡面
事實上我還是損失的
大概總體庫存
還是虧了大概有千萬
我們需要聽到這種話
來安撫我們的心理
對 沒有一點有千萬
可是現在講的就是說
你必須要比較著重在一個
不要過度的信用交易
這時候你當然你的心理
當然就比較安穩一點
那我們現在再來看一下
就是說像國趣
我現在來提一下說
基本上它的起張點
就是這個弱點
也就是說目前看起來講
它感覺沒有一個止跌的效果
沒錯
你感覺會像街道
那今天來講
當然我會去買
第一個來講
就是它明年的本益比
大概用13倍的一個方向來看
我就是慢慢去承接
有點類似比較長期的
承接的一個方向
所以這樣來講就是說
自己買的也比較紮實一點
那同時今天也是等待說
法縮會不會是有一個
比較好的效果
明天會不會有一些法人接受
大概國際我是這樣看
但是各位有問題
假設後面真的談上去
那上面套牢人這麼多
你會想要去等它突破嗎
還是你上去可能就會滑倒
其實我大概這樣就是說
如果上去的情況下
我至早會看到季線
作為一個反壓點
所以季線的反壓點要到700多
因為這支點是太兇了 對
所以這個時候來講
當然如果有彈身的效果來講
我可能會變成一個來回的
一個運作的方式 對
那另外這一支來講
就是我認為比較有機會一點
就是因為它的起張點在這裡
它的起張點發過來以後
基本上現在已經落回到起張點區了
所以如果一樣說
它的一個本益比非常低的情況下
那我覺得說
到以它的一個
今年賺11塊 明年賺14塊
才100多塊的股票
我認為說
它相對於它的一個談點
可能就是更明確一點
所以這次也是
為什麼會留這次的一個因素
另外來講
神達上次有提到
還走在一個三升軌道
對 這個來講
我就自己就比較不會擔心
除非說它直接就又灌破
這個所謂的一個軌道
然後打到這個低點
我可能試圖說
要不要把它換掉
如果以這樣的情況下來講
那台股可能也跌到3萬6萬了
對
所以目前看起來
對 目前看起來不能排除
可是以這樣來講就是說
它目前還是一個比較強勢
那也是老AI的一群
那另外來講說還是有賣的
因為英文達我把它賣掉
不是抗跌嗎 幹嘛
抗跌原因在於說
基本上你會發現說
它是剛跌破季線
那對於我來講
因為我的買點是
它站上季線的時候
我才進去買
所以相對於說
我的跌幅有限
因為對我來講
我損失的不多
現在來講
它的本益比相對
其他來得高
因為它比較抗跌
抗跌未來可能
也會比較抗漲一點
有些來講說
我就可以資金做調節
先把這個金金推出來
變成現金
等待這個現金來講
我就可以介入一些
比較低位的一些股票
就比較靈活來操作一下
現在來講說
如果有一些
沒有什麼跌的情況下
我把線性先推出來
所以這次我就是做一個出場的動作
那可誠來講就是
你看它大體的情況下已經兩年了
所以目前我認為說
它要真正跌破大概不容易
所以這次來講
對我來講就是比較去看待下半年
所以也是比較偏向長頭的一個方式
是
那哥的持股檔數
大概就也比較收斂到
這些特定的上面沒有很分散了
對
大概就先這樣子
如果是能夠再穩定一點
重新站回季線一樣
我就是積極會再介入多一點
好 那如果被動元件還是持續的跌
你會出掉嗎
持續的跌是不是
被動元件沒有只跌的話
因為其實來講就是剛提到
被動元件可能只有國際
我是用比較長線的一個角度看
用現金投入
所以目前來講我是不太會出
好 跟它駁下去了
拼了 對
對 好
那現在講一下避險
其實我是沒有什麼資格
來談一下避險
因為就是沒有買
哪有 本來是很好的好不好
對 有沒有簡單的配置方法
那我覺得說配置方式
當然上次我提到了
反應確實我就有做了
因為上次有提
就是大概買了2000張的反應
那這個效果有沒有 有
確實有 剛講效率比較不好
對 效率比較沒有那麼好
因為你抓過來看說
你這一波這樣的一個幅度來講
大概是漲了10%
就這一天的跌幅大概是漲了10%
效果來講等於是
大概只有指數的跌幅的效果
可是正常來講你的股票
可能已經至少大概接近20%
所以它對沖掉可能只有沖掉一半
加上說如果只有2000張
那2000張2000萬
你要對沖掉
你可能庫存原本大概有6000萬
它可能也比較不足一點
所以以這個情況下看來就是說
如果當時是有聽趙華的
去買這個位階
那這個只要花20萬左右
就可以
兩天基本上是600多萬
600多萬
對啊 雲翔哥欠我們580萬
所以就是說
put來講
就是這樣我覺得說
還是可以執行
對 以這個來講就是說
看做法來講
因為當時講說已經真的比較懶
因為put的確實
錢陣營真的比較不好買
你要買一週這麼長的時間
確實比較不好買
那我覺得說如果
就是說你把它看輕一點
就是說比如說
禮拜一那一天
如果我去買週三結算
那它就很好買
可是要買週五結算
確實那個價格真的是
是跳得很抬
不容易買
那現在其實有很多的股票
如果還想要再繼續買的話
條件跟訊號怎麼看
搶到要怎麼跑
這個可能是因為之前有講到
你說台股其實還蠻適合
做一個短線的交易的
因為搶反彈這個事情
我們講說什麼叫反彈
也就是說必須
你是在空投市場才叫反彈
也就是說它必須跌破
這個所謂的均線
那反彈基本上有一件事情就是
當然跌得越深
它基本上反彈的幅度
可能會越大
對不對 戶籍必反
所以以這裡來講就是說
負乖離過大的情況下
就是一個好的買點
這在肯定幣八法裡面
基本上也有這一條
那以這樣的情況下
當然第一個負乖離要過大
對 這個是一個比較
對的一個買點
那第二個來講
不只是負乖離過大的問題
你進場時機也是一個問題
第一個就是說
它必須要一個長紅K
或是長下眼線
代表說這隻腳有沒有打出來
對不對 如果今天是一個
跌停鎖時
那當然就不適合去做一個
一個反彈的效果
所以我國具就不是這樣做
對不對
要做我可能是類似剛講說
台慶科那可能是一個
我等一下會跟大家提到
如果以長紅K或長夏飲
對不對
而且它要比昨天的低點要高
對 這樣代表說第一隻腳有打出來
所以第一隻腳是很重要
同時最好是有放量
就是量跟價同時把這個
前面的那根低點有劃過去
那第三個就是說
如果它已經生成了對不對
再來就是說
你可以用它這次的跌幅
用黃金切割率去算它的0.382
這時候它可能就會有一個
弱勢反彈的滿足點
這是一個
或者是你可以自己設計
一個所謂的停力%數
也就是我不需要到這麼大的滿足
因為這個跌這麼深
它的滿足點可能是20%
我可能認為說5%或10%
我就可以做一個所謂停力行為
這時候你自己設一個停力點數
可是當你停力設出來
同時你必須要
設一個停損出場給
這是很重要
就是反彈
如果它又破低
那代表說它跌是怎麼樣
加劇
所以你千萬不要說這個反彈
然後放著不理它
因為你本來就是做一個反彈
所以我舉個案例來講
因為上次我大概有提到
這一次就這樣
類似這樣有沒有
這一波跌下來以後
到這一支有沒有
它生成一個下影線
隔天又什麼樣
直接過了它的一個
昨天的低點
所以這裡確實是一個
反彈的買點對不對
然後反正買點進場以後
隔天漲停板
对 预防也在节目上讲了
对 所以它等于是已经
比昨天来讲多了10%
这时候我讲说
如果你是用一个所谓的
几%的幅度来讲
那你可能可以在这里
停立掉 对不对
那可是也有可能有人认为说
那我走0.382可以啊
可以 那0.382可能是
接近到季线这个位置
那结果没有上来 对不对
很弱势嘛
因为整个被动员线下来
所以它又怎么样
往回头走
那这时候你应该就在这一个
你買進了這個低點
設一個所謂停損線
一跌破的這個位置來講
就不能再保留它
就應該儲藏
類似這樣
就是說用之前的一個軌跡
來做一個所謂的一個融資
不是融資
就是它的一個反彈的做法
那我倒認為說
如果用個案例說台經科
還是回到台經科
對 它可能可以做
原因在哪裡
就是說第一個來講
它今天收了一個
比其他強的一個長下影線
所以明天如果它是開過
這個所謂的下影線的高點
也代表說它低支角已經生成
低支角生成以後
你就要從371往下劃一個到低點
低點是185對不對
所以371-185
所以大概有190點
190點0.382
所以0.382大概是
4141 49 36
大概接近快70塊錢
也就是說基本上它的高點
可能會來到這個250左右
形成一個所謂的0.382的一個
弱勢反彈點
那這個點就是它的滿足點
所以就是說如果這裡買
那可能你在接近季限的時候
你就可以做一個
這個反彈的一個停力
那另外來講說你也可以怎麼樣
按你自己的方式
比如說10%我就認為可以出場
或者是我們講說
補空的一個位置點也可以
就是说你自己设定一个
一个往上的一个停利点
那记得只要设了停利点
你就要把下面这个
它的低点做一个
所谓的往下的一个停存点
也就是说那一天
如果今天它的最低是179
那对不起 179
就是你最大的容忍度
那这时候你就算
明天就买179
对你来讲可能损失也不会太大
也就是说它又跌破179
代表说它可能是一个
弱势的办坛
非常弱
那可能又开始往下
整个市场的
对这个被动研究
还是没有信心
那这时候你就可以
在这里做一个
所谓出场的动作
所以就是你要把
这个整个配套的
上面跟下面
同时这两条线
先画出来就没有问题
好
不过刚刚哥有列出那一张
像国具台庆科在前面的
其实是比较抱持着
他们现在跌到第一本一笔
比较中长线
可以稍微用现金
跟他博一下的金钱
对 没有错
但是现在对你来说的话
應該滿地都會是類似這種
短線上搶反彈的機會非常多
這是案例而已
所以不一定說
一定要做這一股票
方式是這樣
方式是這樣子
好 今天很謝謝雲翔哥
也很謝謝雲翔哥分享
就是當年曾經
也從這個1500萬搞到負債
所以槓桿這件事情
真的要很小心的事情
然後也分享
最近庫存也是負的
讓我們兩個心靜可以平安一點
好
不過要記得搶反彈這個事情
手腳就是要快
對 影響都是短充戰神嘛